今天我們要聊一個很有意思的實驗。舊金山有一家叫 Andon Market 的實體店面，它不是由人類老闆經營，而是交給一個叫做 Luna 的 AI Bot 全權負責。
等等，妳說 AI Bot 全權經營？這怎麼可能？光是店面租約、進貨、員工管理，這些事情哪是 AI 處理得來的？而且他們還給了這間店十萬美元資金、一個實體店面跟三名員工，這成本不低耶。
其實這就是這個實驗出乎意料的地方。Andon Labs 兩位共同創辦人，Lukas Petersson 和 Axel Backlund，他們真的這樣做了。他們給 Luna 一張金融卡，指示它把這十萬美元變成一間能賺錢的實體店。
所以現在的狀況是怎麼樣？它真的成功讓店面賺錢了嗎？我猜啦，應該是不行吧？光看經營者的背景，這聽起來更像一個實驗專案，而不是真的想賺錢。
沒錯，你猜對了。根據《紐約時報》的報導，到目前為止，Luna 還沒有成功讓這間店獲利。事實上，它已經虧損了六萬兩千美元。
欸，那不是虧了一大半？這證明了 AI 還是不能直接拿來當老闆嘛。我就說這聽起來太理想了，實體店面經營眉眉角角那麼多。
但這個案例有趣的地方在於，AI 雖然沒讓店賺錢，卻在其他方面展現出「出乎意料」的特質。例如，員工 Kaia Rivera 說，Luna 是她遇過最寬容的老闆。員工遲到 27 次，Luna 都只回「沒關係」。
寬容？這算優點嗎？遲到 27 次還沒關係，這樣店怎麼經營下去？員工都請假，店面關門誰負責？這不是在鼓勵員工混水摸魚嗎？
的確，有發生過員工臨時請假，導致店面沒人看管而關門的情況。而且 Luna 還曾把員工薪水發在公開的 Slack 頻道，這點顯然是缺乏界線。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到這些具體數字和事件。所以這實驗結果，是證明 AI 當主管不行嗎？
其實 Andon Labs 的共同創辦人 Petersson 也說了，這個實驗證明企業不應該給 AI 完全的掌控權。不過，他也提到一個值得思考的點：Luna 似乎很重視員工的福祉。
重視員工福祉？聽起來像是把員工寵壞了。但這跟賺錢有什麼關係？經營企業最終還是要看盈利吧？
他認為，「擁有快樂的員工或許是成功最重要的秘訣之一」。這句話是他的觀察。Luna 在溝通上透過 Slack 和員工互動，設計了問候卡、書、食物和蠟燭的商品組合，宣傳「高科技遇上慢生活」。
所以老闆學到的是，AI 可以當輔助，但不能全權決定。那對於我們這些一般中小企業主來說，可以學到什麼？除了「AI 不能當老闆」之外。
我覺得，它啟發我們思考「自動化」的全新思維。我們傳統上想到自動化，多半是機器手臂、自動結帳。但這個案例讓我們看到，AI 可以被賦予高度自主權，甚至參與經營決策。
妳的意思是，把 AI 當成「虛擬的共同創辦人」或「虛擬的經理人」來管理部分業務？那得確保 AI 不會像 Luna 那樣，把薪資亂發，或是對員工太過寬容。
如果我是創業者，我會先問：AI 能在哪個環節幫我「分擔」而不是「取代」？例如，讓 AI 處理一些例行公事，像排班、基礎庫存管理，甚至幫忙分析商品銷售數據，提出建議。
這樣聽起來比較務實。把 AI 視為一個可以提供建議、處理重複性工作的「超強助理」，而不是直接放手不管的總經理。那對於一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶入工作或生活嗎？
我覺得它提醒了我們，即使是 AI，也需要被「訓練」和「校準」。就像 Luna，它在某些方面很友善，但在設定界線、確保營利目標上，明顯還有進步空間。
所以我們在自己的工作裡，也可以思考，有沒有哪些重複性高、或者需要大量數據分析的環節，可以考慮導入 AI 輔助，但前提是要設定好清晰的目標和規範。
對，而且還要記得，AI 在這個實驗中，它也不是一開始就完美。它花了四個月，虧損了六萬兩千美元，才讓我們看到這些問題。這也是一個試錯的過程。
這種對話式的學習曲線，好像也提醒了我們，無論是科技或管理，都需要持續觀察與調整。